[موسيقى]
تعود جذور الازمه السياسيه الليبيه الى
حقبه الانقسام الحاد في مراحل والذي تطور
الى اقتتال في مراحل اخرى اخر فصول الخلف
السياسي وتفسير القاعده الدستوريه وهو ما
يهدد تنظيم انتخابات البرلمانيه ورئاسيه
ترى انتظارها نقطه الخلاف الرئيسيه والتي
عطلت التوافق على القاعده الدستوريه كانت
احقيه ترشحي مزدوج الجنسيه فهذه المساله
يصر عليها رئيس مجلس النواب عقيل صالح
ويرفضها بشده رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله
خالد المشري والمعني بها بشكل اكبر اللواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر لم تفلح اجتماعات
لجان تم تشكيلها لحسم المساله ولا لقاءات
مباشره برعايه اطراف اقليميه جمعت صالح
والمشري في احداث اي اختراق في جدار
المواقف الصلبه الى ان اطلق المبعوث
الامامي عبد الله بتلي في السابع والعشرين
من فبراير شباط الماضي مبادره جديده
لاجراء الانتخابات خلال العام الجاري
مبادره باتيلي تقضي بانشاء لجنه تتولى
اعتماد اط القانوني وجدول زمني ملزم
لاجراء الانتخابات هذا العام الى جانب
التوافق على شروط منها تامين الانتخابات
واعتماد ميثاق شرف للمرشحين خطه مبعوث
الامي حركت مياه السياسه الراكده في ليبيا
اياما بعد اعلان خطته في مجلس الامن صوت
مجلس الدوله في جلسه رافقها الجدل على
اقرار التعديل الدستوري الثالث عشر الذي
سبق واقره مجلس النواب في السابع من
فبراير شباط ويقضي التعديل بانتخاب رئيس
دوله بشكل مباشر وبرلمان بمجلسين واحد
للنواب في بنغازي واخر للشيوخ في طرابلس
لكن نقطه الخلاف الرئيسيه في شروط الترشيح
تم ترحيلها الى لهجه سيتم تشكيلها لاحقا
تضم سته اعضاء يرشح مجلس النواب وسته
اخرين يرشحوا مجلس الدوله ما يعني استمرار
الجدل نفسه لكن في لجنه فرعيه في غياب اي
مؤشر على رغبه الاطراف في تغيير مواقفها
السابقه ومن بعيد يراقب رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميد الدبيب المشهد ويشترط
خضوع التعديلات الدستوريه للاستفتاء
الشعبي لحصولها على الشرعيه ويتفق مع
المشرف في مساله رفضه عوده العسكريين الى
الحكم